in the heart of farming country in the
Netherlands you'll find the daily
routines of agricultural life
the perennial tending of pasture and
stock but here too you'll find a
different kind of farm where it's eels
that are nurtured and grown
one-and-a-half million a year producing
legally 250 tons of a national delicacy
we grow them up to market size that's
between a hundred and thirty grand two
hundred grams and then they are going
alive to the smokehouses
mostly in Holland be zeals start life
thousands of kilometres away deep in the
Sargasso Sea in the Atlantic Ocean they
drift on the Gulf Stream as elvers or
glass eels
to the estuaries of European rivers
every year a legal quota is caught for
aquaculture to be grown on as adult eels
for consumption but that's where the
unscrupulous strike it's estimated that
300 million glass eels a year are
trafficked to Asia
recent busts have demonstrated the scale
of the problem and illicit trade worth
billions
the end result serves smoked to
unsuspecting consumers in Japan China
and beyond
they're leaving Europe at a euro each
and one year or so later grown on in the
nine hundred ponds of China they are
there have a tenfold increase in value
so 300 million eels 300 million euros
one or so years later that's three
billion euros this is the greatest
wildlife crime by a mile over the
centuries the lakeside town of Volendam
was made rich by eel fishing but with
the species now down to an estimated ten
percent of original totals the industry
has all but disappeared but Volendam may
yet have something to offer the fish
that made it famous it may just be that
to break the cycle of illicit trade you
just need to crack the code of the Eels
life cycle here at a privately funded
laboratory they're trying to find out
how to breed the European eel from egg
to adult something that has a loo
it's science to this day the project
here is focused on getting the
reproduction of the European ill to make
it available for therefore humans so
really to to reproduce the ill in
captivity so that we can supply their
ill farms with with glossy Oh
the problem is replicating precisely
what happens in the Sargasso Sea and
figuring out what the eel love I eat
once that solved the wild eel
in the meantime the focus is on
enforcement and international
collaboration to take the pressure off
this extraordinary species Nick lark
al-jazeera Volendam Netherlands